[Music]
on may 18 2021 ziggo the largest dutch
cable operator announced to the world
that it would no longer control the
rights for broadcasting formula one in
the netherlands
what immediately followed was not much
because who actually spends time looking
at ziko's twitter feed but after dutch
formula one fans realized that this
would mean signing up for the streaming
service via play for the very
unacceptable dutch price of 14 euros per
month fans would begin to start getting
angry
what made this change more notable
however was that the dutch weren't alone
only a year before nordic entertainment
group the owner of via play also secured
a deal that acquired them continued
exclusive rights for formula one in
every single nordic country from 2022 to
2024 this was followed by an expansion
into the baltics pivoting off of ice
hockey as well as acquiring exclusive
rights for formula one in poland
their intentions
clear before the end of 2023 we will
expand via play from our current five
nordic markets to 10 new international
markets and we will grow our via place
subscriber base from 3 million to 10.5
million in 2025. our goal is to be the
european streaming champion
europe is not known for its streaming
services to no surprise american media
remains dominant everywhere and as the
amount of streaming subscriptions
increase in europe europeans continue to
consume mainly american licensed content
a question to ask is if you're a
european company that wants to become a
streaming giant that can compete on the
european market how could you do it
you could maybe try to take a bet on an
entirely new medium for mass consumption
and rely on a base of consumers that are
eccentric enough to get dvds delivered
through the mail you could rely on
decentralized content loaded with ads
submitted by users with no social life
and an inability to tell their parents
they're doing something meaningful with
their lives you could rely on your
globally successful brands and people's
nostalgia but you could also of course
just be jeff bezos
what makes nordic entertainment group
the leader of the pack when it comes to
european streaming companies is that it
has a combination of strategies that no
other european media company has been
able to fully replicate
they invested in streaming services when
it wasn't financially feasible to do it
they rely and still do on a bed of
nostalgic nordic content people across
the world love to act like they consume
and probably the most important thing is
that they did something netflix hasn't
space and netflix is directly going
after your territory it's opening up an
office in the nordics later this year in
stockholm it's saying by the end of the
year we'll have nearly 70 original
titles coming from the nordics so it is
going after your space whether you're
from the same background or not how will
you compete with someone now with such a
deep wallet so a deep pocket as netflix
when it's making original content like
this well the original content that you
refer to is take time to build up we
have 129 original titles on our platform
now when we're stepping up and we're
moving into producing content in other
territories as
as well
what we do have that netflix don't have
and i do think that the different uh
sort of backgrounds matter is that we
have a long history of producing
world-class sports productions
and we've moved that over to streaming
and we produce more than 50 000 live
hours of sports and that's a very
different platform experience and that
allows us to move into
into new territories in a different way
where netflix and other globals don't
compete
sports are a form of entertainment that
has historically been sticky and
remained a domain of linear tv
live sports rides are not cheap after
all and a lot of exclusive sports
streaming deals operate at a loss while
mainly being used for advertising the
larger streaming service
live streaming sports is difficult to do
and re-watching sports would not be as
common as doing the same for popular tv
shows this is why some companies will
package sports into documentary style
content that can stay relevant
profitable for longer periods of time
it's this investment into sports content
even though it would seem like would
only produce losses that separates
nordic entertainment group
they've taken a bet on inelastic demand
dedicated formula one watchers will go
to where formula one is being shown even
if it means paying a higher price and
nordic entertainment group will then try
to keep them with original content that
they hope will be more profitable in
each respective country
dutch viewers will now be given their
own via play original version of
dragon's den alongside others polish
viewers polish murderesses and estonians
to who shot on o'muller
max verstappen also announced along with
his father a multi-year content
partnership with via play to produce
documentary-style content even when he
originally rejected working with drive
to survive because of its supposed
sensationalism
the reason for paying an insane amount
to get verstappen is simple
with almost a cult-like following by
acquiring him to produce exclusive
content nordic entertainment group can
try to turn skeptical formula one
motivated potential dutch subscribers
into enthusiastic ones
[Music]
in 2018 eu officials slept on a
directive to try and encourage american
streaming companies to uphold some form
of minimum european content
however eu directives are practically
always legally obscure because it's
encouragement by the eu for each member
states his own specific legislation
rather than a concrete requirement for
what they have to do and either way the
directive may not even be that necessary
as subscriber growth stalls in america
streaming services will then try and
compete for international markets by
also producing original content in other
countries
for euro files this may seem like a good
thing in itself
but again there are nuances
where do the borders for what is
european content begin and end
the french have been advocating for an
even larger percentage of air quotes
european content but people know france
there is no other european country
probably as culturally anxious about
anglo-saxon content
it's part of the reason some europeans
see the european efforts by the french
as merely a trojan horse
is the 60 french requirement of european
content automatically the same as 60
european content or is it merely a means
for boosting the french
it leads to an interesting question is
content originating from europe
important in itself
it's a question i'm not qualified to
answer because i know nothing and i
ironically have way too much of an
american accent but is one you can try
to by spending your valuable fleeting
conscious time getting angry on the
internet
[Music]
you